have you cheated on chelsea  define shooting  she's got a friend called shannon  can you swap phones please unlock and  swap together  i don't know what to say oh boy but i  was gonna say cheat and then it but i'm  not i haven't done it yet well  how much money would your girlfriend  probably leave you for i feel like  grounded a man said grand so you really  need to win this obviously  don't stop you know that he messaged me  sarah that's a that's that's a buddy  if you had to change one thing about  your boyfriend his height oh  the speed  what did  your boyfriend tell you his body count  was before after her  wait what  what part of each other do you think  he'd be most attracted to  these are looking like they're looking  at each other  same way you message freddo  it's his girlfriend i'll  look forward to meeting you at the gym  um yeah it'll be great to see you  emotional damage  [Music]  you